aujourd'hui je perds tous mes abonnés on
a tous envie de dire que la démocratie
c'est bien mais pour pouvoir conclure
cela un utilitariste devra montrer que
la démocratie conduira au bonheur du
plus grand nombre
souvenez vous pour un utilitariste aucun
moyen ni principe n'est moralement bien
a priori tout principe n'est bien dans
un contexte donné que s'il permet dans
ce contexte à plus de gens d'être plus
heureux
du coup la question c'est est ce que la
démocratie permet vraiment le bonheur du
plus grand nombre dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
alors avant d'aller plus loin il me faut
faire un point sémantique comme on en a
déjà parlé il ya peu près autant de
définitions du mot démocratie qu'il y a
de citoyen et non votre définition n'est
pas plus juste que celle d'un autre
il s'agit d'une définition pas dans
théorème dans cette vidéo juste histoire
que l'on puisse s'entendre sur une
définition je vous propose de nous
arrêter sur la définition littérale du
mot démocratie qui signifie
littéralement le pouvoir au peuple
du coup est ce que donnait le pouvoir au
peuple permet le bonheur du plus grand
nombre a tellement envie de dire oui
mais pour aujourd'hui j'aimerais
questionner notre hooliganisme
démocratique en vous présentant cet
argument contre la démocratie
l'objectif est patent de vous convaincre
que la démocratie c'est mal
l'objectif est surtout de vous montrer
qu'une autre hooliganisme démocratique
est bien moins justifiées que ce que
l'on pourrait croire
et qu'en particulier la démocratie est
loin d'être un devoir moral
déontologique inébranlable voir elle
peut être nuisible au bonheur du plus
grand nombre
argument un la dictature de la majorité
à moins de vivre en anarchie avec tous
les problèmes que ça pose comme on a
parlé dans l'épisode 16 vivre en société
requiert de s'accorder sur des règles
communes comme toute personne qui a déjà
vécu en colocation le sel parfois on
peut s'en sortir avec des solutions
assez consensuel cependant bien souvent
nos préférences individuelles sont
rapidement en conflit les unes avec les
autres et il faut un moyen de trancher
en particulier la démocratie ça ne peut
pas être la prise de décisions qui
conviennent à tous tout simplement parce
que en général
il n'existe aucune solution qui
convienne à tous et comme on en a parlé
dans le dernier un axiome avec monsieur
fille l'inaction et
une décision c'est la décision de la
préservation du statut quo des leurs
tranches généralement via le principe tu
majorité et ça ça revient à dire que la
démocratie c'est avant tout une
dictature de la majorité une dictature
de la majorité ou dit autrement c'est un
système de choix social où les minorités
n'ont pas leur mot à dire
argument de la lenteur de la prise de
décision alors bien sûr on peut souvent
être plus consensuel qu'à travers une
décision via un scrutin sauf que trouver
une solution consensuelle
ça nécessite de donner le temps à chacun
de s'exprimer et de l'écouter quand il
parle
alors quand on est trois ça va mais
quand on est 100 mille ou 60 millions
ça devient vite compliqué et même un
effort partielle de décisions
consensuelles peut prendre une éternité
en fait même la mise en place d'un
scrutin ou d'un simple doodle parfois
entre amis peut prendre beaucoup de
temps
bon j'avoue parfois c'est ma faute ce
n'est pas pour rien si le 4 août 1914 au
début de la première guerre mondiale
président de la république française
raymond poincaré déclare à l'union
sacrée pour autoriser l'autoritarisme
des pouvoirs français est la fin des
querelles démocratique et ce n'est pas
pour rien non plus les membres de
podcasts science ne se sont pas
organisés en état démocratique et ont
préféré désigner un dictateur j'ai bien
compris parfois malgré lui pour que le
podcast puisse tourner à plein régime
argument 3 les citoyens sont pires qui
nous rend littéralement la démocratie
c'est le pouvoir au peuple
et ça en fait ce n'est le cas dans aucun
pays démocratique
donc tous les pays démocratiques il ya
même une grande sous partie de la
population n'a pas le droit de
candidater pour devenir représentant ni
même le droit de voter lors d'élections
démocratiques
vous voyez de qui je parle je parle des
mineurs des moins de 18 ans nos
démocraties interdisent c'est trop jeune
citoyen de participer à la vie politique
pourquoi l'explication la plus avancée
est que ces mineurs sont trop ignorants
pour que leur voix doivent compter mais
à ce jeu là ils sont loin d'être les
seuls si un jeune de 17 ans il trop
ignorants pour voter on peut
légitimement se demander si ce ne serait
pas aussi le cabba
la plupart des adultes et oui parce que
je ne suis pas sûr que le taux de succès
au bac de la population adulte soit
supérieur à celui des jeunes de 17 ans
alors vous allez me dire le bac c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'il faut savoir pour
bien voter
certes et je vous répondrai que
l'ensemble des connaissances nécessaires
pour un vote assez bien informés des
passes mais de loin le cadre du bac sans
inclut aussi des connaissances de
géopolitique de philosophie politique de
philosophie morale d'économie de finance
d'environnement d'écologie d'énergie de
technologies de santé de bien cognitive
de sociologique voire de biologie de
chimie d'histoire et de géographie
bref j'ai bien peur que la quasi
totalité d'entre nous sommes beaucoup
trop ignorants pour un vote assez bien
informés
en fait c'est pire que ça qu'on aimait
le démontrer le statisticien hans
rosling sur de très nombreuses questions
de société nous sommes pires qu'ignorant
nous penchons du mauvais côté dans bien
des cas notre connaissance est
strictement inférieure à celle d'un
chimpanzé qui répondrait au hasard la
bonne réponse est si souvent l'opposé de
ce que l'on croit or la démocratie c'est
le triomphe des croyances les plus
populaires y compris lorsque celles ci
sont pia ignorante
à cumont 4 les citoyens sont
irrationnels imaginez que vous soyez
jugé pour un crime que vous n'avez pas
comme votre sort sera déterminé par un
procès et en particulier par le jury du
procès sauf que avant que le procès ne
commence
les neuf jurés vous regarde droit dans
les yeux et vous disent qu'ils ne liront
pas votre dossier qui ne coûteront pas
votre défense que leur décision est déjà
prise
qu'ils ont vu votre gueule est
clairement vous avez une gueule de
coupables je pense que vous trouverez
cette forme de justice injuste
sauf que selon un philosophe john
brennan ce type de procès est une
parfaite illustration de la démocratie
telle qu'elle est pratiquée à travers le
globe
comme l'expliquent très bien stéphane
sur homophobes luce nos choix politiques
sont un jugement de faciès effectué en
100 millisecondes
alors je suis sûr que vous avez tout
plein d'arguments pour justifier vos
positions politiques
mais comme l'expliqué jonathan ait notre
intuition prend position
bien avant que notre raison se lance
dans un raisonnement motivé et ne
collectent que les arguments qui
conforte notre intuition et il ne s'agit
pas uniquement de notre attitude
vis-à-vis de politiciens dans tout plein
de débats de société
nous prenons position bien avant de nous
intéresser au détail du départ sauf qu'à
l'instar des décisions d'un jury les
décisions démocratiques ont des
conséquences graves
elles correspondent à l'autorisation
d'utiliser la force
typiquement via les forces de l'ordre
pour obliger les citoyens à se soumettre
à la volonté démocratique y compris
lorsque cette volonté démocratique et
irrationnelle en démocratie nos
concitoyens ont un droit de vie et de
mort sur nous et ne prendront pas le
temps de réfléchir à notre sort
argument 5 les incentives des médias et
politiciens dans un système démocratique
il faut l'appui du peuple et pour avoir
l'attention du peuple
en pratique il faut éviter de parler des
nombre de catalans ou des cycles de
milankovitch pour que le peuple
s'intéresse à nous au point de penser à
voter pour nous il faut faire le buzz
comme on en a déjà parlé dans l'épisode
9 pour un homme politique ou pour un
média le pire n'est pas de dire des
bêtises en fait de nos jours il semble
même que ce soit une bonne chose de dire
des bêtises
puisque ça attirera l'attention
populaire le pire ce n'est pas de dire
des bêtises le pire c'est d'être ignorés
et pour ne pas être ignoré le plus
simple et le plus efficace c'est de
créer des polémiques à tout va et à
exagérer l'importance de ce qui
intéresse le peuple
j'entends parfois dire que la démocratie
requiert des politiciens et des médias
de qualité
malheureusement il me semble que la
théorie des jeux prédit que la
démocratie implique des politiciens
populistes et démagogiques et des médias
catastrophiste et pita clic les
conditions d'une démocratie idéale
semble incompatible avec les incentives
engendrés par la démocratie
argument cisq la politique créée
l'hooliganisme la politique
abruti et corrompt affirme john brennan
autrement dit plus les citoyens
s'intéressent à la politique plus ils
choisissent un camp et surtout plus ils
défendent leur camp de manière
irrationnelle
cette remarque est là rien d'évident a
priori et les théoriciens du xviiie
aurait largement pu en douter certains
philosophes pensait même que
l'implication politique des citoyens est
les conduire à leur épanouissement et
cette idée persiste encore aujourd'hui
puisqu'il est souvent considérée
intellectuelle que de s'intéresser à la
politique et à l'actualité et d'avoir un
avis sur tout débat de société
cependant les sciences sociales
empirique ne cesse de démontrer le
contraire
dans les épisodes 10 et 11 on a vu à
quel point l'hooliganisme politique
inhibé nos capacités intellectuelles et
dans l'épisode 27 on a vu pourquoi cette
hooliganisme est une composante
importante de la nature humaine
selon jonathan wright la sélection
naturelle à sélectionner notre désir de
protéger et rationnellement nos
semblables car la sélection de groupes
était la clé de la survie humaine
cependant parce que les politiciens
doivent faire le buzz plus doivent
chercher à former une coalition
majoritaire
ils vont nécessairement faire appel à
l'hooliganisme en nous de sorte que dès
que l'on s'intéresse à la politique on
est voué à être tiraillée par des appels
à notre hooliganisme ainsi l'implication
politique semble voué à se transformer
en hooliganisme politique ce qui selon
john brennan à poti et corrompt
d'ailleurs c'est pas un hasard si on
évite de parler de politique lors de
grands repas de famille ou avec des gens
dont on a de bonnes chances de ne pas
partager les opinions politiques par les
politiques ça éveille l'hooliganisme en
nous si on est avec des partisans dont
on partage les convictions on risque de
subir la polarisation de groupes qui
pousse à l'extrémisme et en présence
d'avis contraire on semble voué à
souffrir de discussions qui sont et
plaisante
alors que quand on n'est pas où ils
gagnent en fait des avis contraire c'est
souvent très intéressant
argument cette la démocratie coûte cher
en travail humain le révolutionnaire et
président américain john adams disait je
dois étudier la politique et la guerre
pour que mes enfants puissent avoir la
liberté d'étudier les mathématiques et
la philosophie
autrement dit pour ce politicien la
politique n'est pas une fin en soi
l'idéal serait une société sans devoir
politique ne société où chacun pourrait
se préoccuper de ses passions et
uniquement ces patients est bon quitte à
passer pour une enflure à titre
personnel me concernant c'est aussi mon
idéal de société
j'aimerais pouvoir passer mon temps à
faire des mathématiques avoir des
discussions philosophiques avec des
logiciens que j'adore à lire les
réflexions et les découvertes des grands
scientifiques et des grand vulgarisateur
des sciences et à me balader dans des
paysages magnifiques
j'aimerais ne pas avoir à m'intéresser à
notre politique et encore moins à
l'actualité aux hommes politiques
ça va peut-être des pères à plus d'un
mais je trouve l'actualité les faits
divers et les polémiques entre hommes
politiques
incroyablement ennuyeux surtout
comparativement à la beauté des
mathématiques et j'ai tendance à penser
que beaucoup profiterait davantage de
leur vie s'ils s'extasiait des
merveilles des sciences et de la
philosophie au lieu de continuellement
s'informer de l'actualité politique
mais pour beaucoup l'exigence
démocratique impose un devoir moral à
chaque citoyen à s'informer et à se
faire des avis sur des sujets de société
qui pourtant sont souvent très loin de
nos domaines d'expertisé ou d'intérêt
l'exigence démocratique impose un devoir
moral à prendre le temps et à dépenser
l'énergie nécessaire pour décrypter
l'actualité poétique et pour aller voter
je vais sans doute passer pour un énorme
flemmard mais la démocratie exige un
travail de la part de chacun de ses
citoyens et il me semble que cette
exigence de travail de la part de tous
est un énorme point négatif dans le
calcul utilitariste
il arrive souvent que de nombreux débats
présuppose inconsciemment que si une
décision est démocratique
alors il s'agit d'une bonne décision ou
encore que tout irait beaucoup mieux
dans nos sociétés si nos sociétés
étaient davantage démocratique on admet
communément que la démocratie c'est bien
et on construit souvent nos réflexions
politiques autour de ce postulat est ce
que je trouve très problématique c'est
que ce postulat n'est quasiment jamais
remis en cause alors que il n'a rien
d'évident si vous n'avez jamais remis en
cause les bienfaits de la démocratie
je vous recommande vivement de livres
qui critiquent la démocratie celui de
l'économiste brian caplanne dont on
apparaître dans l'épisode 11 et celui du
philosophe john brennan au titre très
explicite against démocratie j'ai trouvé
ces deux livres très convaincant en fait
ce qui suggère c'est qu'étant donné tout
ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui de la
manière dont les électeurs votent
l'utilitarisme et très certainement
contre la démocratie ou du moins contre
l'hooliganisme démocratique qui consiste
à dire qu'il faut plus de démocratie
dans nos sociétés mais alors quelles
sont les alternatives à la démocratie eh
bien je dirais justement que notre
difficulté à penser à autre chose que
dictature montre justement que nous
avons des oeillères au moment de penser
à ces questions et que nous nous rendons
pas compte que dès aujourd'hui la
quasi-totalité des prises de décisions
collectives ne sont en fait ni
démocratique ni dictatorial caplanne
fait justement remarquer que les prix et
les quantités des biens que nous
trouvons supermarchés ne sont pas du
tout choisi de manière démocratique et
qu'il peut s'agir d'une très bonne chose
comme beaucoup d'économistes
sensibiliser à la main invisible d'adam
smith et je vous renvoie vers les
excellentes vidéo de monsieur fie à ce
sujet caplanne insiste sur le fait que
beaucoup de marchés fonctionnent
incroyablement bien et agir de façon
démocratique sur ces marchés
typiquement par protectionnisme pour
éviter les augmentations des prix ou
pour créer plus de job risque de
dérégler les marchés et de les rendre
moins efficace ce qui sur le long terme
risque de conduire à des pénuries ou à
des inflations catastrophique
brennan lui ai fait valoir ce qu'il
appelle les pistes au cra 6 ce qui
signifie littéralement le pouvoir au
savoir il s'agit des cas où une décision
est prise par un ensemble d'experts
plutôt que par l'ensemble de la
population
c'est le cas par exemple du statut des
théorèmes mathématiques si un théorème
est considérée vrai ce n'est pas
parce que le peuple l'a votée en
référendum et ce n'est pas non plus
parce qu'un dieu mathématiques il a
déclaré dictatorialement la validité des
théorèmes mathématiques et la vie
combiné d'une poignée d'experts qui
s'accordent pour reconnaître la validité
de la preuve du théorème comme on en a
parlé avec monsieur fille dans le
premier axione et en fait ce que tel
processus sont omniprésents pour toutes
sortes de sujets qui requiert une
expertise que ce soit l'économie la
finance l'énergie l'ecologie les ogm les
vaccins la technologie la sécurité du
chiffrement informatique et l'éducation
le citoyen médian n'a pas son mot à dire
sur la prochaine norme html l'audit des
entreprises du cac 40
la crédibilité de la mécanique quantique
les priorités de la recherche en santé
ou la rationalité du nom bretons et
c'est sans doute une bonne chose sur de
tels sujets techniques
il semble que les décisions et piste aux
pratiques maximiseront bien plus le
bonheur globale que des décisions
démocratiques et si mes calculs
utilitariste sont justes il s'agira
alors d'un devoir moral utilitariste que
d'exiger l'absence d' influence
démocratique sur de telles questions
l'année enfin on a parlé de travail avec
gilles de la chaîne peut rien et vous
avez été plusieurs à souligner qu' on
n'a pas du tout fait la différence entre
le mot travail et le mot emplois en
effet je pense qu'on va parler pas mal
du mot travail non sens économique
je pense aussi qu'on a utilisé le mot
travail tout simplement dans le sens le
plus commun ne pas chercher à avoir des
discussions closeau fixe sur ce qu'était
le travail
et si c'était bien ou mal on a cherché à
vraiment à utiliser la manière dont les
gens pensent le travail et je pense que
c'est très important donc on fait des
vidéos de vulgarisation de parle avec
beaucoup de gens comme cela de s'adapter
d'adapter notre langage à tel qu'il sera
entendu et non pas d'essayer d'imposer
la sémantique reconnu par une petite
communauté plus généralement comme vous
l'avez compris dans cette vidéo
je trouve que bien souvent trop souvent
en fait on a tendance à vouloir imposer
notre perception de démo à d'autres
personnes
alors que le but de mes vidéos c'est
plutôt de communiquer des idées et pas
de disserter sur les différentes
interprétations possibles sémantique de
différent et ça me permet aussi
d'insister sur un point très négatif à
mon sens des morales déontologiques ou
même plus généralement de dire qu'on
attribue beaucoup de valeur à un truc
qui est identifié par un mot par exemple
typiquement dire que la démocratie c'est
bien je trouve que cette phrase est très
problématique parce que souvent en fait
on va prendre ça comme le truc à
défendre devenir un peu oui yann de
cette phrase
la démocratie c'est bien et pour pouvoir
défendre notre position
on va ensuite déformer le sens des mots
et on va ajuster le sens des mots
pouvoir justifier nos principes
déontologiques ou de les valeurs morales
un peu dogmatique que l'on attribué aux
différents objets bref je pense qu'il ya
énormément de manipulation de décence
des mots qui sont dus à une combinaison
de principes déontologiques et de la
morale des hooligans qui font que on a
envie de défendre ce qu'ils veulent on
considère sacré comme par exemple la
démocratie une fois qu'on a sacralisé la
démocratie c'est impossible de la
critiquer et c'est impossible de voir
ses limites et ses défaillances
puisque à chaque fois on peut toujours
modifier la définition du mot démocratie
pour que finalement ça marche bien et à
ce moment là chacun sa définition du mot
démocratie
bref je ne suis pas une bonne façon de
raisonner à mon sens typiquement un
exemple de ça commentaire de yens une a
fait valoir que certains travaux sont en
fait
moralement bien notamment il souligne le
travail non rémunéré
retraités qui apporte finalement
beaucoup de bien utilitariste à leur
entourage
et du coup on veut dire que le travail
c'est bien donc littéralement dans le
commentaire de yanina
il ya une phrase qui dit que je
travaille est une valeur importante
qu'il faut promouvoir mois tels que je
comprends du commentaire en fait c'est
pas le travail qu'il faut promouvoir
dans ce cas ce qu'il faut promouvoir
c'est l'action qui va conduire à plus de
bonheur général samir après une
interprétation un peu utilitariste mais
en particulier ce qui est bien là ce
n'est pas le travail ce qui vient dans
l'exemple qui est donné en tout cas
c'est pas le travail en tant que tel ce
sont les conséquences du travail et donc
tout ce qui apporte plus de bonheur oui
il faut le promouvoir bien sûr mais le
travail en tant que tel est ce qu'il
faut vraiment le promouvoir
il me semble que cette conclusion est
blessée par le fait qu' on a modifié le
sens du mot travail parce qu'on voulait
défendre ce principe à la base
bref je fais encore intervenir des
principaux utilitariste mais en tant que
guitariste il n'y a pas à dire ça c'est
bien ça c'est pas bien c'est ça dépend
du contexte et des surtout des
conséquences des différentes actions en
particulier le mot travail regroupe
tellement de choses et certaines qui
sont pas forcément bénéfiques qui
apporta façon en plus de bonheur au plus
grand nombre
du coup c'est un peu bizarre de dire le
travail c'est bien quand ils disent tous
- des contre exemples où je travaille et
pas forcément moralement justifiable du
cas d'un point de vue utilitariste je
sais qu'il y en a qui ont un peu marre
que j'utilise beaucoup point de vue dit
triste mais je trouve que c'est très
utile le point de vue utilitariste pour
justement sortir de ses positions un peu
hooligans que l'on a sur des principes
déontologiques ou sur des valeurs comme
attribut certains concepts alexi bales
sergeac nous dit que les rues les plus
riches n'ont pas intérêt à faire ça donc
je pense qu'un peu de encore une fois
dans ce commentaire est plus riches sont
pas forcément méchant je renvoie vers
les sections vidéo de monsieur fille sur
nietzsche qui explique très bien comment
la réaction anti riches et une réaction
finalement à ces hooligans
c'est nous contre eux en particulier
comme on vit en partie en démocratie où
il ya quand même des représentants qui
te veulent être réélus et qu'ils ont
intérêt pour être réélu à prendre des
décisions démocratiques
moi je dis a plus que ce qui fait que ça
ne change pas c'est surtout que la
plupart des gens veulent plus de job
c'est cette même un débat assez
récurrent comment créer plus de job
comme si c'était évident qu'il
s'agissait d'un devoir moral de créer
plus de job une société serait meilleur
c'est avait plus de job et l'argument de
la vidéo précédente c'est justement que
si on en est arrivé là c'est parce que
beaucoup de gens sacralise le travail
hors d'un point de vue utilitariste ya
aucune raison de scènes de sacraliser le
travail ce qu'il faut surtout c'est que
chacun et tout ce qu'il faut pour bien
vivre et sans doute que dans les années
à venir
avec l'avènement de l'automatisation ce
sera de plus en plus possible et ce en
outre souhaitable je reviens un peu ce
truc administratif parce que moi
personnellement j'ai vraiment pâle
administratif est tellement de travaux
un deal qui pourrait être juste éliminé
quand notre disant juste les bons outils
informatiques mais pour en arriver là il
faut supprimer des diables partie tuer
dès aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils ont déjà
utile de désacraliser un peu de travail
et l'autre chose que je voulais dire par
rapport à ces séries mechri c'est que en
fait à bien réfléchir je pense qu'ils
ont en fait pas mal intérêt à ce que et
de redistribution des richesses
encore une fois comme explique que
souvent très bien gilles sur armoricain
l'idéal pour eux c'est d'avoir les
entreprises qui tournent sans son
travail parce que ça coûte cher le
travail et l'autre truc c'est que le
sentiment d'insécurité dans la
population
avec l'avènement de l'automatisation
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait être
une menace pour les riches et à ce
moment là je pense que riches ont tout
intérêt de façon assez égoïste à
redistribuer les richesses ou quelqu'un
qui traite rech
la valeur marginale de l'argent est
finalement très faibles c'est-à-dire
dollars quelques autres affiches ne
change pas grand chose par contre le
sentiment d'insécurité qui pourra
ressentir avec une population qui qui
qui est récente par exemple c'est
quelque chose qui peut avoir un coût
plus important que la perte d'un dollar
est l'exemple très classique de cela ce
sont l'investissement dans les écoles
finalement investir dans les écoles
c'est une très bonne stratégie pour les
riches puisque ça permet d'éduquer et de
voir plus de demandes de qualité à
l'époque mais plus de personnes éduquées
qui vont réduire le sentiment
d'insécurité et puis on va faire une
société plus intéressante
je pense que beaucoup de riches ont
beaucoup d'intérêt à ce que
il ya une redistribution des richesses
qui ne se fasse pas uniquement via les
emplois et en particulier je pense que
stigmatiser les riches comme ça c'est
forcément une bonne stratégie
attention à l'organisme youth applaudira
considère que la vidéo précédente était
anti capitaliste alors on serait sans
doute étiqueter des deux communistes aux
états unis avec la vidéo précédente mais
en fait c'est des choses qui à mon sens
autre ensemble de très largement le
clivage capitaliste versus communiste
est en fait qu'un que penser selon ce
clivage créer un peu fait monter le
hooligan en nous et nous fait prendre
parti et c'est sa mauvaise façon de
faire est en fait si on regarde les
travaux de beaucoup d'économistes
souvent catalogué capitaliste comme par
exemple milton friedman il y a des idées
de redistribution des richesses et en
fait je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'économistes actuel qui considèrent de
plus en plus le revenu de base comme
étant où la redistribution des richesses
de façon plus générale comme étant
quelque chose de bien même si ces gens
là sont aussi en train d'admirer la
l'efficience des marchés et la main
invisible d'adam smith je pense que
c'est tout à fait compatible de dire
waouh ça marche incroyablement bien les
marchés et de dire il faut distribuer
aussi de richesse malheureusement quand
on tombe dans le clivage capitalisme
versus communisme on est incapable
d'avoir cette vision de l'économie qui
pourtant aujourd'hui me semble faire de
plus en plus consensus
plus généralement alors des deux
dernières vidéos je trouve qu'il a
énormément de hooliganisme dans les
commentaires on en a parlé un petit peu
dans ma réaction
3 alors forcément laborde des sujets
plus sensibles donc c'est plus difficile
de de retenir le wigan qui est en nous
du coup j'étais un petit peu dépassé
j'ai pas censurer le légalisme dans les
deux vidéos précédentes mais on va
remettre ça en place dans cette vidéo
qui est très punchy maintenant que je
suis revenu de vacances je vais
supprimer à nouveau les commentaires qui
sont trop ou liane elle espère que vous
avez aimé cette vidéo la prochaine fois
on va parler de wikipédia m
wikipedia c'est un système qui n'est pas
démocratique qui est beaucoup plus et
piste aux pratiques justement qu'il ya
un mécanisme qui est souvent imparfaite
mais qui finalement donne des résultats
qui sont d'une qualité absolument
incroyable donc on va parler de
wikipédia la prochaine fois si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à la ligue et à
la commentent et partagent pensez à vous
abonner et à la culture épisode merci
aussi peur pour leurs dons et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois que
je lis